hot breath best ways to recognize
sharpen and develop your persona slash
voice oh man
i gotta tell you that's a good question
when i was coming up i asked everybody
that question
i i'm over for pete holmes and asked him
i asked tom papa
i asked everybody when i was starting
out because i was like what the hell is
your voice what is that why is
why has everybody found theirs and not i
haven't found mine
and somebody told me i forgot who but
somebody gave me the great advice is
look at all your jokes that work
and find the common link between all
those jokes
and that's probably your voice why do
you keep going back to these why is this
subject matter touched on a lot why is
this like this why'd you pick that
material whatever it is
and that helped me and listening
yourself
and you go oh that's a that's a joke i
would tell or you listen to your friends
ago that's such a mark joke that's a
and you're like really and then you go
okay so what the hell's mark
what the hell is that you know and just
it's all about clues
and remembering everything take it all
in so for me i figured out eventually
that my
stick is it's basically saying
if this is like that then why isn't this
like that and that's my whole act
yeah nice i don't see color well then
i'm black
no you're not ah you know just by
inconsistencies